my name is Marley Dias I am an author
and an activist so when I was ten years
old I was a very avid reader and in my
fifth grade class I didn't see black
girls as the main characters in any of
the books that we were assigned and we
actually got into the classroom the
books were just mainly about like boys
and dogs so I've aimed to collect 1,000
books where black goes with the main
characters and now over the past four
years I've collected 12,000 books for
black girls of the main characters and
written my own book which is called
Marley Dyess gets it done and so can you
and it's essentially about how kids can
use their passions and things they care
about to create change in the world
one Trailblazer that's really inspired
me and kind of pushed me to be great is
Augusta Baker
she's an unsung hero really of the
literary world she worked in the New
York Public Library for 37 years and she
did a lot of work on diversity and
inclusion and even though I wasn't alive
when she was alive I know that I follow
in her footsteps and the work that she's
done really created a way especially on
the east for kids and for adults
especially black adults and black kids
to care about diversity it's kind of
amazing to think that I never knew who
she was when I started my campaign and
obviously she never got the chance to
meet me or hear about me when she passed
away in 1998 but it's like the fact that
our work is so closely aligned that I
can see I use her history in her example
and shine in her light and figure out
what I'm gonna do with my campaign next
so it's really inspiring especially when
she started her work in like the early
1940s that she was living in a
segregated world where so many people
didn't care about the narratives of
black people and she really had to be
both smart strong and brave which are
things that I try to be with the work
that I do
she what about the work that she did in
a very respectful way where she wanted
to make sure that the kids that were
reading these books weren't pushing out
the stories of white people weren't
pushing out the stories of the majority
and I try to use that lesson of letting
people know that I care about what white
people have to say I care about what
black people have to say I care about
what Pacific Islander Asian Latina
people with different abilities have to
say and the campaign is about creating a
space for all rather than pushing one
group out and letting other groups in I
try to apply a bakers work into mine by
making sure that I allow for kids to
know that their voices matter too and
encouraging them that the power of
reading really allows for them to become
changemakers and to become people that
adults care about and want to listen to
so we can become the next generation of
people
that changed the world my message to the
next generation which is really my
generation is to use their passions of
the things they're interested in as a
fuel for change